dans une tombe doublée en béton,
dans un cimetière.
Au total, dans les cimetières américains,
on enterre assez de métal pour reproduire le pont du Golden Gate,
assez de bois pour fabriquer 1 800 pavillons
et assez de fluide d’embaumement plein de formaldéhyde
pour remplir huit piscines olympiques.
De plus, les cimetières à travers le monde sont presque pleins.
Il s’avère qu'économiquement parlant, il n'est pas logique
de vendre à quelqu'un un bout de terrain pour l’éternité.
(Rires)
Qui a eu cette idée ?
Dans certains endroits, même les riches ne peuvent pas acheter de parcelle.
Du coup, les taux de crémation sont montés en flèche.
En 1950, si on suggérait d'incinérer sa grand-mère après son décès,
on se serait fait renvoyer du chevet de la mourante.
Mais aujourd'hui, presque la moitié des Américains choisissent la crémation
car elle semble plus simple,
moins chère
et plus écologique.
Je pensais que la crémation était un procédé durable d'élimination,
mais pensez-y une seconde.
La crémation détruit le potentiel que nous avons
de rendre à la terre à notre mort.
Elle utilise un processus énergivore pour convertir les corps en cendres,
polluant l'air et contribuant au changement climatique.
En fait, les crémations aux États-Unis
émettent un total impressionnant de 272 155 de tonnes de CO2
dans l’atmosphère chaque année.
La terrible vérité
est que la dernière chose qu'on fera sur Terre
sera de l'empoisonner.
Comme si on avait créé et accepté un statu quo tout en niant notre mort
et en mettant autant de distance entre nous et la nature
qu'il est humainement possible.
Nos pratiques funéraires modernes sont conçues pour diminuer
les réactions du corps après la mort.
En d'autres termes, elles sont censées stopper la décomposition.
Mais la vérité
c'est que la nature est douée avec la mort.
On l'a tous vu.
Quand la matière organique meurt dans la nature,
les microbes et les bactéries la mélangent à un sol riche en nutriments,
complétant le cycle de la vie.
Dans la nature, la mort créée la vie.
En retournant à l'école d'architecture, je réfléchissais à tout cela,
et j'ai pensé à un plan pour repenser les soins mortuaires.
Pourrais-je créer un système
bénéfique pour la Terre
et qui voit la nature comme un guide plutôt que comme une menace ?
Quelque chose de doux pour la planète ?
Cette planète, après tout, porte nos corps vivants
toute notre vie.
Quand je tournais tout ça dans ma tête,
sur ma table à dessin,
le téléphone a sonné.
C'était mon amie Kate.
Elle a dit : « Salut ! Tu as entendu parler de ces fermiers
qui compostent des vaches entières ? »
J'ai dit : « Hmmm. »
(Rires)
Il se trouve que des fermiers des institutions agricoles
font ce qu'ils appellent le compostage de cadavres d'animaux
depuis des dizaines d’années.
Composter un cadavre, c'est prendre un animal riche en azote
et le couvrir de matériaux de co-compostage riches en carbone.
C'est un processus aérobie donc il a besoin d’oxygène
et aussi de beaucoup d'humidité.
Dans un cas classique, une vache est couverte d'un mètre de copeaux
riches en carbone
et elle est laissée à l'air libre pour que le vent apporte de l’oxygène
et la pluie de l'humidité.
En environ 9 mois,
tout ce qui reste est un compost riche en nutriments.
La chair a entièrement disparu,
tout comme les os.
Je sais.
(Rires)
Je pense donc pouvoir me qualifier de geek de la décomposition
mais je suis très loin d’être une scientifique.
Et ce qui le prouve
c'est que j'ai souvent qualifié ce procédé de « magique ».
(Rires)
En résumé, notre mission en tant qu'humains,
est de créer le cadre idéal pour que la nature puisse travailler.
C'est l'inverse du savon antibactérien.
Au lieu de les combattre,
on accueille les microbes et les bactéries à bras ouverts.
Ces magnifiques petites créatures
décomposent les molécules en molécules et atomes plus petits,
qui sont incorporés à d'autres molécules.
En d'autres termes, cette vache est transformée.
Ce n'est plus une vache.
Elle a été rendue à la nature.
Vous voyez ? Magique.
Imaginez l'ampoule qui s'est allumée dans ma tête
après ce coup de téléphone.
J'ai commencé à concevoir un système
basé sur les principes du compostage de cadavres d'animaux
qui prendrait les corps humains et les transformerait en terre.
Cinq ans plus tard,
le projet a évolué comme je n'aurais jamais pu l'imaginer.
On a créé un modèle urbain évolutif, reproductible et non lucratif
basé sur la science du compostage de cadavres d'animaux
qui transforme les corps humains en terre.
On s'est associé et on a collaboré avec des experts en science du sol,
en décomposition, en soins mortuaires alternatifs,
en droit et en architecture.
On a obtenu des fonds de fondations et d'individus
pour concevoir un prototype de ce système
et des centaines de milliers de personnes à travers le monde
voulaient que cette option soit disponible.
Ok.
Dans les années à venir,
notre but est de construire le premier service complet de compostage humain
dans la ville de Seattle.
(Applaudissements)
Imaginez.
Une partie parc public,
une partie maison funéraire,
une partie mémorial pour les personnes que nous aimons.
Un endroit où nous pouvons nous reconnecter avec la nature
et traiter les corps avec délicatesse et respect.
L'infrastructure est simple.
Dans un noyau vertical,
les corps et les copeaux subissent une décomposition naturelle avancée,
ou compostage
et sont transformés en terre.
Quand quelqu’un meurt, leur corps va dans un centre de compostage humain.
Après avoir enveloppé le défunt dans un simple linceul,
les amis et la famille portent le corps jusqu'en haut du noyau
qui contient le système de décomposition naturelle.
Pendant la cérémonie de dépôt du corps,
ils le placent délicatement dans le noyau
et le recouvrent de copeaux.
C'est le début de la lente transformation de l'humain en terre.
Les semaines suivantes, le corps se décompose naturellement.
Les microbes et les bactéries rejettent carbone et protéine
pour créer une nouvelle substance,
une terre riche.
Cette terre peut être utilisée pour créer la vie.
Un jour, vous pourriez être un citronnier.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Qui pense à une tarte au citron meringuée maintenant ?
(Rires)
Une pastille au citron ?
Plus fort ?
Donc en plus d’abriter le noyau,
ces bâtiments permettront de soutenir les endeuillés
en fournissant un espace pour les funérailles et les dispositions.
Le potentiel d'exploitation est énorme.
Les vieilles églises et les entrepôts peuvent devenir des endroits
où on peut créer de la terre et honorer la vie.
On veut rétablir l'aspect rituel
qui a disparu ces cent dernières années
à cause de la hausse des taux de crémation
et du déclin de l'appartenance religieuse.
Notre centre de Seattle représentera un modèle pour ces lieux
dans le monde entier.
Des communautés d'Afrique du Sud, d'Australie,
du Royaume-Uni, du Canada et d'ailleurs nous ont contactées.
On a créé un outil de conception
qui aidera les autres à concevoir et à construire des centres
qui renfermeront des spécifications techniques
et les meilleures régulations.
On veut aider les individus, les structures
et par la suite, les municipalités
à concevoir et à construire des centres dans leurs villes.
L'idée est que tous ces lieux paraissent différents
tout en ayant le même système.
Ils doivent être conçus pour les quartiers dans lesquels ils sont installés
et pour les communautés qu'ils servent.
L'autre idée est d'avoir sur place une équipe d'accompagnement
pour aider les familles à préparer les corps de leurs proches.
On bannit les pratiques déroutantes et paralysantes
et on créé un système beau et important.
Et transparent.
On pense que l'accès à des soins mortuaires écologiques
est un droit.
Vous connaissez ce vieux dicton qui dit :
« Si tu compostes une vache, pourquoi pas un humain ? »
(Rires)
Il se trouve que c'est vrai.
Depuis 2014, on dirige un projet pilote
dans les collines de Caroline du Nord
avec le Département d'anthropologie médico légale de la Western Carolina University.
Les corps de six donneurs ont été couverts de copeaux,
de l'oxygène étant fournie grâce au vent,
les microbes et les bactéries faisant leur travail.
Ce programme pilote nous a permis de prouver qu'il est possible
d'exploiter la pouvoir incroyable de la décomposition naturelle
pour changer les corps humains en terre.
Et on travaille aussi avec d'autres universités.
Des chercheurs de la Washington State University,
des étudiants diplômés,
travaillent sur le compostage des plombages
pour que l'on puisse comprendre ce qui arrive au mercure.
Ensuite, on commencera des tests
pour déterminer le sort des traitements chimiothérapiques et médicaments
pendant le processus de compostage
et la nécessité d'une nouvelle décontamination.
au fait,
le compostage créé beaucoup de chaleur,
surtout ce genre de compostage.
Une semaine après le début du compostage du corps de notre cinquième donneur,
la température dans ce tas de copeaux
a atteint 70 degrés Celsius.
Imaginez pouvoir exploiter cette chaleur pour créer de l'énergie
ou pour réconforter les endeuillés s'il fait froid.
La révolution des soins mortuaires est lancée.
C'est un grand moment à vivre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)